BRIAN: THANKS SO MUCH, JILLIAN.
27 MINUTES BEFORE THE TOP OF THE
HOUR.
FED UP WITH THE BIDEN BORDER
POLICY HIGH LEVEL ICE OFFICIAL
QUITTING HIS POST AFTER 30
YEARS.
IN AN EMAIL TO HER COLLEAGUES
SAYS THIS.
A NOW FORMER ICE ENFORCEMENT
REMOVAL OFFICER WRITES THIS
QUOTE FROM THIS LETTER TO FIGHT
AND ARGUE EVERY DAY ABOUT NOT
ARRESTING OR RELEASING HORRIBLE
CRIMINAL ALIENS TO THE STREET
QUITE FRANKLY IS DISGUSTING.
THAT’S SOMETHING SIMILAR THAT
TOM HOMAN HAS SAID BEFORE.
RETIRED ACTING ICE DIRECTOR
HIMSELF.
HE RECEIVED THE EMAIL AND IS
TALKING ABOUT IT.
TOM, YOUR REACTION TO YOUR
FRIEND’S MOVE TO LEAF?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, IT’S SAD
THAT SOMEONE SPENDS 30 YEARS
SERVING THEIR NATION THEY ARE
GOING OUT THIS WAY.
THEY ARE GOING OUT AND NOT BEING
ABLE TO DO HIS JOB.
I KNOW THIS MAN IS A FRIEND OF
MINE AND PATRIOT SERVED HIS
NATION FOR OVER 30 YEARS.
HE IS QUITTING BECAUSE HE RUNS A
LARGE FIELD OFFICE.
IS HE A SENIOR LEVEL OFFICIAL
THAT RUNS A LARGE FIELD OFFICE.
HE HAS 700 AGENTS WORKING FOR
HIM.
HE CAN’T LET HIS AGENTS DO THEIR
JOB BECAUSE HE IS UNDER ORDERS
NOT TO ARREST.
CAN’T ARREST ILLEGAL ALIENS
ANYMORE, BRIAN.
CAN YOU BE IN THE COUNTRY
ILLEGALLY.
ICE CAN’T TOUCH THEM AND REMOVE
THEM.
THE CRIMINALS IF YOU ARE
CONVICTED OF ASSAULT THEY CAN’T
ARREST YOU.
THEY HAD A CASE -- I A GUY WAS
CONVICTED OF DUI FOUR TIMES.
FOUR TIMES.
HE WAS ORDERED REMOVED BY
IMMIGRATION JUDGE.
WHEN HE GOT OUT OF JAIL.
ICE HAD TO DROP THE DETAINER
BECAUSE HE IS NO LONGER A
PRIORITY.
YOU HAVE GOT TO BE CONVICTED OF
A SERIOUS, SERIOUS CRIME OR ICE
CAN’T TOUCH YOU.
YOU CAN’T ENFORCE IMMIGRATION
LAW ANYMORE UNDER THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
THIS GUY CANNOT LOOK HIS AGENTS
IN THE EYE EVERY DAY AND KEEP
SAYING NO TO THEM.
YOU CAN’T DO YOUR JOB.
YOU CAN’T UPHOLD YOUR OATHS.
HE QUIT.
OF I WILL TELL YOU SOMETHING.
THERE IS 24 FIELD OFFICE
DIRECTORS ACROSS THE NATION.
I TALK TO ALMOST ALL OF THEM.
THEY WOULD ALL QUIT TODAY IF
THEY COULD.
BUT THEY HAVE GOT MORTGAGES AND
CHILDREN IN COLLEGE.
THEY ARE ALL MISERABLE.
THE MORALE IS DESTROYED.
THIS AGENCY IS NOT THE SAME
AGENCY IT EVER HAS BEEN BEFORE.
>> THIS HAS NEVER BEEN A PARTY
PROBLEM.
WE ALL AGREE ON THE ARREST,
CRIMINALS IN OUR MIDST.
WHEN YOU CROSS THE BORDER.
YOU BROKE THE LAW.
IT WAS NEVER A PARTY PROBLEM.
NOW DEMOCRATS SAY COME ONE, COME
ALL.
AND REPUBLICANS SAY ARE YOU
INSANE?
SINCE WHEN DOES THAT WORK IN OUR
COUNTRY’S BEST INTEREST?
DON’T WORRY, THE VICE PRESIDENT
IS ON THE JOB.
AND SHE OUTLINES HER PRIORITIES.
AND IT’S ALL ABOUT OTHER
COUNTRIES.
LET’S LOOK AT THIS TOGETHER,
TOM.
NUMBER ONE, ADDRESS ECONOMIC
INEQUALITY.
YOU KNOW WE HAVE TO SETTLE NAWJ
INEQUALITY WHEN IT COMES TO
CENTRAL AND SOUTH AMERICA.
ADVANCING THE RULE OF LAW.
MAKE SURE THEY ARE DOING A GOOD
JOB ADVANCING THE RULE OF LAW.
PROMOTING RESPECT FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS.
OH, GOODY SO WE WILL FOCUS ON
GUATEMALA AND EL SALVADOR NOT
HERE IN AMERICA.
COMBATING CRIME AND GENDER BASED
AND DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
THAT WILL REALLY HELP THINGS AT
THE BORDER DO YOU THINK SO?
>> THAT’S A JOKE.
IN SIX MONTHS THEY HAVE DONE TWO
THINGS WROTE 11 PAGE MEMO THAT
MEANS NOTHING.
NUMBER ONE, THAT MEMO SHOULD
HAVE BEEN SECURE THE BORDER AND
ALLOW IMMIGRATION AGENTS DO
THEIR JOB AND ARREST CRIMINALS.
NUMBER GOT ONLY THING THEY HAVE
DONE SUCCESSFULLY, BRIAN, GET
REALLY GOOD AT RELEASING PEOPLE
REALLY QUICKLY.
PRESIDENT BIDEN SAID LAST WEEK
WHEN HE WAS ASKED AT CNN TOWN
HALL HOW ABOUT THE IMMIGRATION
ISSUE?
WE HAVE THE HAVE IT SOLVED.
BORDER PATROL AND CUSTOMS 90%.
RELEASE THEM QUICKLY.
THEY CALL SUCCESS.
I CALL IT ENTICEMENT.
NOW I CAN GET TO THE UNITED
STATES I WILL BE RELEASED
QUICKLY AND THEY WILL BUS ME AND
SEND A PLANE AND GET ME TO MY
FINAL DESTINATION.
BRIAN: THEY FOLLOW OUR NEWS MORE
THAN WE FOLLOW OUR NEWS.
SO, YESTERDAY, A BIDEN OFFICIAL
WAS ASKED, WHAT ARE YOU DOING AT
THE BORDER?
YOU ARE SO CONCERNED ABOUT THE
PANDEMIC AND THE SURGE AND WHO
IS VACCINATED HERE.
AT THE BORDER THESE PEOPLE ARE
COMING IN WITHOUT ANY VACCINES.
WE DON’T KNOW WHO IS TESTING
POSITIVE AND WHO IS NOT.
LISTEN TO THIS EXCHANGE.
>> WHY IS DID THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS ASKING VACCINATED
AMERICANS TO WEAR MASKS TO STOP
THE SPREAD OF COVID-19 BUT AT
THE SAME TIME FEDERAL AGENTS ARE
ALSO RELEASING COVID-19 POSITIVE
BORDER CROSSERS INTO SMALL TOWNS
IN TEXAS?
>> CBP PROVIDES MIGRANT WITH PPE
FROM THE MOMENT, FROM THE MOMENT
THEY ARE TAKEN INTO CUSTODY AND
MIGRANTS ARE REQUIRED TO KEEP
MASKS ON AT ALL TIMES.
BRIAN: WOW.
HEY, MIGRANT, I KNOW YOU ARE
HERE ILLEGALLY AND YOU HAVE
BROKEN MANY, MANY LAWS BUT KEEP
THAT MASK ON.
IS THAT THE WAY IT’S BEING DONE
AT THE BORDER?
>> NO, WHAT THEY SHOULD HAVE
ASKED HER IS CBP TESTING FOR
COVID UPON ARREST?
ARE YOU ALLOWING ILLEGAL ALIEN
TO LEAVE A BORDER PATROL STATION
OVER THE LINE WITHOUT BEING
TESTED?
DOES CBP THEMSELVES THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TEST?
NO.
THEY ARE COUNTING ON LOCAL
COMMUNITIES TO TEST THEM.
THEY WILL GET THEM TO A HOLT
ROOM AND MAYBE TEST THEM HOTEL
ROOM NGO AND GET COVID.
GUESS WHAT?
IT IS TOO LATE.
IN A HOTEL ROOM WITH 300 PEOPLE.
GET THEM ON A BUS AND PLANE.
THEY GIVE A MASK TO 166,000
PEOPLE THEY HAVE RELEASED
WITHOUT A COURT DATE.
GIVE A MASK TO I HAVE GOT 8400
CRIMINALS THEY HAVE ARRESTED.
THEY GET A MASK TO CRIMINALS
THEY HAVE ARRESTED.
49 OF THEM WHO IS CONVICTED OF
HOMICIDE.
THAT COME ACROSS THE BORDER.
274 GANG MEMBERS.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THIS
ADMINISTRATION IS HOLDING
AMERICANS TO A DIFFERENT
STANDARD THAN THEY ARE HOLDING
ILLEGAL ALIENS.
PURPOSELY RELEASING ILLEGAL
ALIENS INTO THE IT NO COURT DATE
AND COVID.
DOESN’T MAKE SENSE.
BRIAN: MAGNET FOR MORE TO COME.
YESTERDAY CAUGHT OFF BIKE.
JOE BIDEN IN THIS RECONCILIATION
PACKAGE GOING TO PUT IN
IMMIGRATION REFORM AND TRY TO
NATURALIZE 8 MILLION ILLEGALS.
THAT’S A GO SIGN TO CENTRAL AND
SOUTH AMERICA TO HAITI, THE
CARIBBEAN, EVERYWHERE AROUND THE
WORLD COME ONE, COME ALL
ILLEGALLY.
LOOK OUT.
AND THE BORDER PATROL IS IN THE
LINE OF FIRE WITH NO SUPPORT.
TOM HOMAN, THANKS SO MUCH.